Lucky walcky sono surgelato mi aiuto Che
cos'è Che schifo
Siamo arrivati a 51 sì
sì sì no ascensore pauroso Guardate
stiamo per entrare nel nuovissimo
ascendants
Guardate questi sono tutti i cattivi che
potremmo incontrare alcuni non sappiamo
quali saranno perché c'è il punto di
domanda Vedi è proprio lui il cattivo il
punto di domanda
sarebbe un bene cattivo Sì interessante
eh Comunque vi ricordate gli altri
episodi in cui entriamo nell'ascensore a
ogni piano ci aspetta un cattivo ma non
perdiamo altro tempo entriamo subito io
uh uh
dove siamo oh oh
ci sono un sacco di altri giocatori Wow
Siamo tantissimi questa volta c'è
qualcuno che sta prendendo fuoco
No credo che quello sia un razzo tipo
l'ascensore Sì
Ah vedi ha una fiaccola in mano lo vedi
potrebbe essere pericoloso Voi lasciate
un bel mi piace perché se questo video
raggiunge i 5.000 mi piace faremo un
altro episodio in cui saliamo
sull'ascensore della paura l'ascensore
del terrore Ecco il primo piano se non
conoscete ancora le regole e chi
sopravvive più a lungo in più piani
vincente vediamo Vediamo chi è questo
c'è un robot tipo un robot mi ha fatto
tipo scheletrico Ma sì ma si attiverà
non fa niente aiuto Non è che ora esci
c'è un altro piano al piano di sopra
c'è un altro piano il piano di sopra Ah
ah ah credo che stia per uscire
[Musica]
io com'è possibile No vabbè abbiamo
perso miseramente era solo il primo
piano primo livello abbiamo già aperto
a sopravvivere di più Ehi ma quanti
siamo i troppi ma chi è che sta mettendo
dei LEGO qua nell'ascensore sapete hanno
riempito tutto e forse per non far
entrare i cattivi no così uno sale sui
LEGO Eh dai provate vediamo chi è il
prossimo cattivo siamo tipo in una
specie di
Jurassic Park Eh sì forse sono i
dinosauri il cattivo odori veramente
Vediamo se lo so ragazzi aiuto
[Musica]
questa nuova Escape Room dell'ascensore
È molto più difficile delle altre è
difficilissimo
il dinosauro è entrato nell'ascensore
deve schiacciarlo appena rientrata nella
sensore sono già sfracellata ok L'ho
trovato qua Ora proviamo a sopravvivere
al t-rex ah ah ah
ma ma ehi ma come si fa
a sopravvivere al t-rex sfracellato di
nuovo Eh la terza volta
Ma com'è possibile Sono rientrato tre
volte tutte e tre le volte mi ha
sfracellato schiacciandomi che devi
scappare velocemente
e ora cosa Ci aspetterà il prossimo
piano vediamo vediamo qual è la fine del
video scriveteci nei commenti Qual è
stato il vostro cattivo preferito Anche
noi vi diremo il nostro preferito Vi
auguriamo che cos'è Peppa Pig
vedi Uh tipo
forse forse non dobbiamo andare Oh che è
successo fighi come hai fatto a pensare
a Peppa Pig
sì E questo è l'interno della testa di
Piggy
basta così però siamo sopravvissuti
quindi prenderemo i punti anche adesso o
che è successo
Sì l'ho vista L'ho vista L'ho vista L'ho
vista Ok Ok Ok Ciao ciao Difficile
questa sensazione dell'errore Sì
Dov'è Piggy ora torno subito da Peggy
questa volta sopravviverò tu non sei
ancora morto No sono sopravvissuto yeah
di nuovo l'ascensore Sono sopravvissuto
a Piggy Non ci posso credere prossimo
cattivo cattivo
questo qua che corre No quello è un
personaggio ehm ci sono delle guardie
hanno aperto la porta
aiuto Siamo arrivati a 51 tipo è un
alieno ovviamente
no ma perché devo morire sempre Ciao
ciao torna a prenderò la mia rivincita e
io sono salito sull'ascensore non puoi
nasconderti Perché i cattivi entrano
anche nell'ascensore vediamo vediamo ma
si può salire da sopra come si fa a
salire là sopra qualcuno è salito tutto
buio Aiuto
qui vediamo cosa
sono morta di nuovo È troppo difficile
in questo nuovo sensore ha preso anche
me ero scappato Però poi dopo m'ha preso
Sì ma ti sei sfracellato anche tu due
volte
prossimo piano velocità super velocità
vai Che figo
Qui siamo in Minecraft Eh non lo so però
mi piace chi è il cattivo qua Eh boh
Forse dobbiamo solo completare
No è impossibile che non ci sia un
cattivo vedrai che arriverà
bellissimo belli bellissimo
Quante volte ti sei sfracellata tu qui
niente ecco come hai fatto sto vincendo
Dai che cos'è quella c'è una gabbia lì
forse il cattivo sarà proprio lì
qua dentro riuscite a vederlo
io sto qua dentro però credo che sia
cattivo e quindi Ma appena si aprirà la
gabbia sarà la fine però è tutto buio
tutto nero non vedo niente Tu lo vedi Sì
lo vedo
Qua si apre svegli sta dormendo
ma io son caduto non mi ha preso
Questo gioco non sopravviviamo proprio
un bel niente Oh no sei di nuovo Anche a
me Eccolo mi sta inseguendo solo
[Risate]
lui è nell'ascensore insieme a me oh mi
era nell'ascensore insieme a me ma non
m'ha preso No vabbè Vitale sta dicendo a
sopravvivere più di me come è possibile
Ehi dove siamo Eh siamo una parolaccia è
una grotta che potrebbe essere il
cattivo qua sairenheit
perché Zelda dovrebbe essere un cattivo
ma perché avete capito i personaggi
mettono dei personaggi buoni per
trasformarti in cattivi Ma perché ci
dirà voi ci attirava verso destra Eh sì
è Zelda Che brutto Uh uh uh uh uh uh uh
mi ha preso di nuovo Sì però là l'ho
fatto troppo difficile questo discorso
non riusciamo a passare neanche un
livello è pure entrato No no
mentre è distratto ah ah sopravvissuta
per questo secondo approccio
all'improvviso e quindi è andata avanti
a posto oh via no di nuovo il dinosauro
t-rex Allora io mi nascondo qua dove qua
Forse quando mi troverò io mi metto qui
dietro nei cespugli invece
se rimaniamo Fermi Forse lui non se ne
accorge Credo che possa sentire il
nostro odore ha distrutto tutto
qui nascosto qua infatti e qualcuno sta
saltando in testa
stanno scappando tutti
dov'è Dov'è dov'è Dov'è dov'è c'è una
luce qua
Fammi controllare Dov'è non riesco più a
vedere Infatti forse siamo Salvi
[Musica]
tutti quelli che si sono nascosti
nell'ascensore adesso sono stati
mangiati dal t-rex Io invece mi sono
nascosto dietro questo cespuglio ancora
non mi ha visto
e infatti è meglio nascondersi questo
Wow
forse forse abbiamo capito come
ingannare il dinosauro
ricoperti dalla foglia prossimo livello
una porta Credo sia la torre vedi Stiamo
salendo i gradini Io sono già morto
dobbiamo salire più in alto possibile
forse è qui e più in alto possibile
dobbiamo fare tutti i piani perché
magari poi si allaga sotto ti ricordi il
movimento della lava Sì è vero
Oh Corri corri Ah ok dobbiamo salire
velocemente perché arrivi la lava quanti
ce n'è davanti a te io sono uno e solo
una Sì forse ce la faccio ad essere
primo primo Eh già Oh no basta sta
avendo sempre più velocemente
sbrigatissimo No vabbè ti ha preso
veramente è difficile anche questo
non ci credo
riuscite a sopravvivere alla lava Son
passato
no di nuovo questo scheletro Aspetta
Allora il trucco qua è enorme dobbiamo
salire sopra qui vedi se tu ti arra Qui
c'è un pulsante rosso Non so che cosa
serva però boh proviamo a premerlo
non riesce ad arrivare proviamo a
nasconderci proviamo
fifone sei nascosto benissimo
io rimango qua in ascensore vediamo se
riesco a sopravvivere Ma sta ancora
sparando fiamme Sì rimango qua
nell'angolino dove sei ritardato
Oh prossimo livello anche luoghi
suggellato non siamo neanche entrati che
giocano così non sappiamo neanche visto
anche i waki vediamo vediamo
Uh ma ogni volta che cagato Vis flagello
non sa che devi cadere nel punto giusto
credo
volando siamo sopravvissuti senza
neanche aver visto il kiwaki boh Che
strano via via via via
pure tu sei caduta ah ah questa volta ti
sconfiggerò non ci siamo dimenticati
diventano un pezzo hai visto hanno fatto
scomparire il parkour Ma insomma andiamo
Stiamo venendo mangiati da fighi Ok Ci
siamo all'interno e adesso tra poco
comparirà sempre questa volta non mi
sconfiggerai vi piace il mio outfit di
oggi sembra che non ho le scarpe sembra
che sono le scarpe solo con le calze
Gohan mi è apparsa davanti ho perso il
lato così Aspetta subito Vitale Vediamo
se io riesco a sopravvivere questa volta
ok Aiuto aiuto siamo rimasti solo in due
provo a ritornare da Pigne Meno male Pig
è lenta
aiuto
Quando finisce Sì sarà sopravvissuto
spiegami perché mi sono sfracellato solo
le strade questi corridoi
chi è Secondo te il cattivo proviamo a
indovinare Non lo so ma fa paura
sembrava
uno scheletro mi ha spiaccicato subito
un fantasma pixel lato
vediamo
Aiuto Anche no Eh sfracellato pure io sì
ma questo è troppo difficile però è come
quello dei muri nelle Escape Room
dobbiamo nasconderci in un angolo angolo
Ma perché allora spiegatemi perché io ho
appena entro buio perché ci sono quelli
là Roblox
Ti aspettano tutti vedi questi qua sono
fatti di LEGO fatti di LEGO sono dei
cattivi fatti di LEGO giganti infatti mi
ha colpito con le ginocchia si è
spiegato
Beh comunque sono più lenti loro credo
Quindi io provo a scappare di qua
dobbiamo stare attenti vedi sono proprio
qua vicino all'ascensore sono troppo
alti per entrare qua dentro
ce n'è due qui vicino all'ascensore non
mi fanno uscire entra qua in questa
casetta Questa è la prima ad uscire come
faccio ad entrare aspetta
sono sono sopravvissuto rimanendo
nell'ascensore Uh uh
uh due tre stella Quindi bisogna stare
attenti a quella bambolina Ehi aspetta
un momento perché si sta avvicinando
dentro Stella al contrario
invece di avvicinarci noi si avvicina
lei e quindi come facciamo adesso Eh non
lo so io provo andare qua no non ci fa
passare bisogna già preso
siamo morti tutti cosa
No è diventato tutto buio ma stiamo
ancora qua ora riesco a passare Davvero
Dov'è la bambolina però
schiacciato dobbiamo sopravvivere il più
possibile allora ci riprovo Eh Credo che
ogni momento metterà dei nuovi ostacoli
Ok Ok proviamo a scappare dietro
l'albero
puoi anche salire sull'albero sono
passato sono passato sono passato
uh ce l'abbiamo fatta prossimo livello
siamo tornati nel mondo di Sonic Questo
è il più divertente perché purtroppo
divertente perché c'è una super velocità
e ci si spregerà
andare da un'altra parte vediamo guarda
aspetta qui siamo nella gabbia che
riuscivi a vedere prima con Sonic Sì e
poi dopo un po' stonic.
e tornare indietro scappa scappa scappa
lui non esce da lì e ti sfracella ma
sono caduto Ma come Oh io non vedo più
niente Non riesco neanche dietro Oh
forse dovevo colpirti È tutto buio Sì
ora c'è lui c'è Sonic che ci sta
cercando ma se volete l'ascensore Ecco
perché
ho capito perché sei tornato indietro Eh
beh sì son caduto Io sto scappando da
Sonic dov'è ma
è la giusta facendo esplodere un po' di
giocatori Finalmente un po' di luce e io
non vedo niente però mi ha preso ma tu
sei riuscita a sopravvivere a Sonic Sì
perché è entrato nell'ascensore Sonic
Fabio
Sì io sono sopravvissuta sono l'unica mi
dispiace
ragazzi oh che cos'è questo nuovo
livello ma è tipo ma è tipo
ma forse ghiaccio è un labirinto quindi
dobbiamo capire dove andare però tra
poco apparirà anche il cattivo quindi
stai attento tu dove apparirà Qui c'è un
buco nero un quadrato nero nero
o forse è lì da dove esce il cattivo
adesso ci credo però
era una trappola quello del corriere non
buttarsi lì no no io sto girando qui nel
labirinto tanto lo sapete che il
labirinto fa male
aiuto ma tanto io non lo troverò mai la
via Qui è tutto buio il labirinto figura
di più che altro
è cattivo invece era tutto illuminato ma
penso che era un altro giocatore
sono spaventato
sopravvissuto sopravvissuto non mi ha
preso era questo giocatore qui vedi
c'avevo tutte queste cose illuminate e
mi ha fatto spaventare nuova vediamo
deve ancora aprirsi qua grazie
per uscire da lì il tipo lo vedete Sì
sta rompendo il muro ci sarà
Secondo me è tipo un robot o un alieno
forse un alieno sembra molto Aria 51
questa
aspetta le luci Oh alieno riaccendi le
luci Ehi ma non è facile eh stasera non
lo so è esplosa la porta e adesso forse
dobbiamo andare qua
è l'unica strada Ok non si passa qua
tutto buio Ah
ah ah
sì lo vedo lo vedo più vicino a me ha
fatto cambiare il colore di tutto quindi
non si capisce niente io rimango Fermo
vissuti
spostati c'è qualcuno che si sta
avvicinando Chi era Non lo so questo è
un hacker sì
che ci fanno il campo da baseball
e la fermata dell'autobus Ah eccolo Ciao
signora che schifo Non ti avvicinare Ti
stai avvicinando a lui sembra buono
Certo forse mi vuole solo mangiare Brava
Vediamo quanto è buono
aiuto Aiutami
tu hai detto sembra buono Peggio per te
Adesso ti sei sfracellato
prenderlo
torniamo subito Devo prendere il
contenuto devo superare con i punti
superato
Però
[Musica]
io torno dentro la sua sorella Aiuto
flagellato Sì sono sopravvissuta Ok
ragazzi ultimi due livelli qualsiasi
cosa capiti dobbiamo sopravvivere e poi
vediamo chi ha vinto tra me e vitale
ultimi due livelli Tra l'altro siamo
rimasti solo in due questo tipo sono io
perché Cos'è questo
come si chiamano
sfp non so cosa
no Challenge Challenge con le unghie
lunghe
Il problema è che cioè adesso è chiuso
in quel vetro ma tra sarà liberato
sicuramente Aiuto
aiuto Ah ma forse si scende da qua sotto
guarda non ti conviene scendere giù
ti ho preso aiuto ha rotto il vetro
ad uscire dal vetro
però se scopre che lì sia un passaggio
dal livello Giusto giusto No se non ti
segue è vero di qua fare in modo che
possiedendo E certo non ti avvicinare
troppo il vetro pompa Ma che vuole
questa domanda oh oh oh oh è riuscito
a scappare no
[Musica]
Eh ma l'ascensore è già chiuso e vabbè
passiamo all'ultimo livello
attento perché ora si avvicina Ma quindi
spostati
e io una domanda per voi Voi dite 1 2 3
stella oppure dite Uno due tre stai là
tu come dici scrivetelo nei commenti per
me Io ho sempre detto uno due tre stella
Noi siamo morti nel frattempo
fa apparire le palle infuocate
bisogna andare nell'albero nell'albero
aiuto
da una palla infuocata E allora è troppo
tardi
io sto qua sopra non mi può prendere
niente No dai mi mancano solo 100 punti
per arrivare a 10.000
più tardi mi sta per raggiungere con i
punti via via via
vincere
Laggiù sta provando a raggiungere Oh dai
facciamo l'ultimo livello Sono curioso
di vedere cosa c'è nell'ultimo livello
mancano solo 25 punti vediamo ultimo
livello Chi vincerà questo problema
dell'ascensore
Che cos'è questo di nuovo lo Yeti No è
di nuovo Slender Man ti ricordi
Il problema è che non so dove
nascondermi da lui troppo veloce ma tipo
non lo so tipo Mettiamoci qui eh qua non
siamo ben nascosti neanche qua aprite
questa porta Però come si fa ad
inchinarsi provo a nascondermi qua no
Uffa Non c'è nessun punto per
nasconderci Vabbè mi metto qua Sperando
che non ci veda
ah
via io io Ciao ciao Oh ma qua è tutto
chiuso Dove sta andando
tu no sono rimasto sorpreso Aiuto
Sono sopravvissuta a credermi come hai
fatto Non ci posso crederci come dice
Vitale
è arrivato anche un altro giocatore e
questo è l'ultimissimo livello Baggio
sappiamo che qua arrivati tipo una sorta
Ah ah ah ah cresci Allora Quanti punti
abbiamo fatto io
11.325 punti e io 10.350 Hai vinto tu
Brava brava
Federica Qui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione Ciao